it's the dry season in the sahaja here
in the South American Savannah that
means forest fires are commonplace the
next few months will be busy ones for
Manuel far es de Oliveira and his
colleagues forest fires are
unpredictable and potentially very
dangerous full before the shot mystical
about this one if we wait until the
evening to start putting out the fire it
will have spread too much besadii
thought this is a high-risk area and the
flames can spread very fast it's best we
make an effort to put it out straight
away we're going to try and stop it
coming this far maybe that blob let's
get the news item is the firefighters
use basic tools to try to contain the
flames many of them are farmers working
as firefighters to earn some extra money
it's back-breaking work and there's no
let-up in these parts there's always a
fire raging somewhere hey so buddy what
you see in that bin yeah it depends on
what time of year the fires begin
whether it's rained much yes if it
hasn't rained much there are more fire
so I'm using steam I spoke on average we
see 250 to 280 fires per season in
Samantha's instance we think the folks
more often than not they've been started
deliberately slash-and-burn practices
have already destroyed more than fifty
percent of the sahaja Savannah and with
it a unique natural habitat
in Montero's a town in the middle of the
protected area they're setting up a
firefighting center the project is being
funded by Germany to the tune of 8.5
million euros it's geared not to putting
out fires but seeing how they can be
used to benefit the region an
observation satellite is now in use in
the area I don't you shake I didn't it
it helps us understand how the fire
spreads whether it reaches any natural
limits whether we can let the fire run
its course and if it's necessary to
intervene or not this sort of
observation is now possible at the
National Park Center this fire for
example tells us that the area is very
dry so someone needs to go along and
check it out this is a u.s. to local
FEMA search go usually this will be done
by plane the protected area of jalapa
alone is as big as Switzerland fires
like this one are usually caused by heat
or lightning it's impossible to contain
them and they're too far away for the
firefighters to deal with
controversially farmers javan and mon
allow have long relied on traditional
slash and burn agriculture even though
the technique used to be banned in the
protected area get cynical figure 5 in
if we're not allowed to use our
traditional techniques then we can't
maintain the quality of our produce and
we also end up producing less now
however the practice is once again legal
but only so long as the fire brigade is
on hand
well see up 10 deals of you choose down
when you own your that we've not been
working together since the beginning of
the year because we want to reconcile
the goals of the protected area with the
needs of the local population disappoint
abilities regardless we put the fire
brigade at their disposal so as to
prevent the fire from spreading and at
the same time we guarantee that the
local population can continue using
their traditional farming methods yes we
reached a binding agreement and we want
to work together harmoniously yeah hey
Anya the carbon in the ash makes the
soil more fertile and burning clears
land for new crops
the fire management program in the
Sahara is designed to help Brazil reach
its ambitious climate goals by 2020 it
hopes to have reduced its carbon dioxide
emissions by nearly forty percent
the calm before the storm there could be
an emergency at any minute sometimes the
firefighters have to spend days battling
flames their camps are out in the middle
of the forest sometimes the fire brigade
starts fires themselves here in this aha
do it's better to live with fire than to
constantly battle it Laura style from
the Brazilian Institute of environment
and renewable natural resources says
these steps are necessary for the
conservation of the sahaja estamos
pasando aqui a which it is all fo prob
remastered what this is is a controlled
blaze hi we create a firebreak path that
prevents the fire from spreading it gave
me an apology that's part of the
integrated fire management programs say
to my auto monies you think that I need
to know fire to make it work managing it
entails prevention containment
firefighting and using fire as we see
here so you it's a program that
contributes to the preservation of
biodiversity in Brazil and the reduction
of greenhouse gas emissions swab UofL
saddaji thumping had those zeros and soy
de guises the Fate to school foot but
reducing the entire country's carbon
emissions would entail introducing the
strategies practiced in the shallop I'll
protected area across the whole of the
Sahara
you